tchèque à brno et manu
vous aimez les bons soirs à soir ça et
ce qui se passe dans un communiqué
alors vous faites le morning sur nrj le
swing sur tps dire que vous bossez de 6h
à 9h du matin et de 19 à 20 heures d un
peu entre les deux c'est quand même
ouais on bosse en gros de 6h à 21h le
soir et vous baisez quand bal après la
haye tout de suite après qu'on tarde pas
trop nous n'aurons s'arrange sur les
plateaux voilà qu'on passait beaucoup au
plateau on s'arrange pour concilier les
deux pas mal
ouais ouais on a les loges spéciale on a
un sens du rythme qui est pas mal on
commence à la voir parce qu'on débute au
frais donc on n'est pas super au point
vous n'êtes pas vieux 1 que tu as toi au
moins 36 a quand même et lui la mongie
30 ans arrêt assez mieux déjà tué annick
et là sur ce coup-là d'être sur ce coup
là par contre tu connais laurent baffie
toi oui on se connaît pas ce qu'on a
reçu laurent sur le plateau du soir qui
élit son coup faire alors à laurent
battut va nous raconter c'est comment
cette émission très sympa ah ouais c'est
très très drôle très bien fait ils ont
pleins d'empathie ibl s'il prépare des
magnétos et des fausses pubs ça rappelle
un peu les grandes heures des nuls
maintenant si bien foutu s'est produit
parfait rhodia donc ses parents faim
aujourd'hui que jamais à l abri des
mages désormais donc ouais ouais ouais
je suis déstabilisé je m'étais préparé à
des vannes de laurent baffie d'un
compliment du coup ça m'a vous merci
laurent vais-je si vous voulez y annonce
à ses voiles annoncé on s'est bien marré
web vraiment il ya un truc qui bien en
tous les cas dans votre émission c'est
qu'il ya l'interview piqué ah ouais et
là vous dites
l'émission vous dit l'animateur vite le
joug s'est passé imagine si le co et
faisait ça c'est acquis 10 avec qui vous
a sauvé
dans le cas des missions c'est ça ouais
ouais ouais hein on le fait mais parce
que on s'est dit tiens il y en a
tellement qu'ils le font sans le dire
que nous et ses impôts bien au fait de
bien c'est le décor ce plus beau des
causes mais sont très bons mais souhaite
par ailleurs
ah ouais bah comme ce que je propose
c'est qu'on regarde à quoi ça ressemble
non je vais regarder votre caméra tous
les deux et vous dis ah ouais mais sale
ya un jour où ça arrivera pour sa maman
ouais c'est celle ci est oui dit magnéto
sur cinq grands mots